greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by hymns
listen 66 of percent of men lose their
head by the age of 35 did you know that
the thing is when you start to notice
hair loss it's too late like me I'm
starting to losing my head but who cares
I'm 55 you follow me it served its
purpose well with it it's easy to keep
the hair you have than to replace the
hair you have lost you see them same
thing let me ask you a question thanks
to science baldness can be optional so
what I don't feel this I got a one-stop
shop for hair loss skin care and you
ready for this one sexual wellness for
men hims connects you with real doctors
and medical grade solutions to treat
hair loss without having to break the
bank for him calm his his run I need for
you to do order now I'm gonna give my my
family the church a trial month two
hymns for five hours that's it right now
while supplies last see the websites for
full details this will cost you hundreds
of hours if you went to a doctor or
pharmacies and just go to hims calm /
Joey that's four hymns FRR hims calm /
Joey number two listen you're a fat [ __ ]
you want to get it again you want people
people are hanging on you're trying to
[ __ ] flip you over and sweep you you
want adorable gear you gotta go with
[ __ ] fuji they've been around since
jesus lud chicago you understand me
when jesus trained jiu-jitsu you [ __ ]
bought a jeep from fuji a lot of people
don't know that however fuji
fuji top tip top Magoo from the
all-purpose $99 one to the separate
ofuji sports comm is there fear go to
fuji sports.com right now press in
church bad get 10% delivery right to the
[ __ ] crib you understand me lee kick
this [ __ ] meal this is a beautiful
day to be alive
my main man and studio the [ __ ]
joe chilling is in the studio sitting
next to the Christ killer and Mickey's
in the [ __ ] house what's going on
here except uncle jelly is beautiful
you're just one word now Mickey like
Prince yeah it's Mickey I like that
Mickey Rourke is done all the other
Mickey's are done Mickey it's done all
the
he's a nun there all the time they're
sucking dick you're the malp and common
Mickey it's is Mickey yes sir
that's it Mickey Mantle's dead I don't
feel so good myself Mickey Rooney Hornet
Mickey's a [ __ ] dial yeah you're the
only Mickey God walk the rest look that
did hell he had the face never again did
you hear from they gave a couple million
you never seen him again he's cut his
toenails [ __ ] it's Mickey yeah that's it
all [ __ ] day Martin look from now
that's how I get on my shorts fella
I like that and your punch when you're
not people on it's called the Mickey
okay moving in the 70s whenever you put
a cosmic pillar is called a Mickey yeah
people know that was Nick you'd wake up
somebody slipped me a Mickey less
they're not you [ __ ] ass no you ate a
quail oh I did yeah yeah the quaalude no
wonder you [ __ ] up I'm in he said I'm
sold
that's it that's it what's up Joe hey
nobody good to see ya thank you very
much for the gifts and okay you know you
don't [ __ ] around I'm Jewish you showed
up with an envelope I said you should
have put edibles pampas favorite no
[ __ ] around some people show up with
like a [ __ ] strew I don't want to
screw it was it yeah what's going on
gentlemen
everything is raining
yeah been here for three months got here
training with this guy a lot you know uh
all over the place I'm having a blast
and working hard you know this is my
calmly this is the other side of mmm
well this is like Tommy you're going out
of your comfort zone to somewhere else
like when you start comedy you start
like in Denver and you're there for like
a year now uh-huh then somebody comes to
you says you got to go on the road and
you start going on the road and then the
[ __ ] hotels of shitty and people
getting murdered next door to you sent
you here women getting banged and the
hookers and [ __ ] like that but they have
the road yeah and this is what you did
you got out of your comfort zone in New
Jersey you can't wear your training with
this [ __ ] killer the killer did
better in the [ __ ] business with
hands and feet elbows or I'll blow you
to [ __ ] death yeah you take one out
but I'll still [ __ ] kill you with the
one out bow oh just keep like oh [ __ ] it
I told these guys I had a teacher panic
uchi that's I'm gonna call you panic
cootchie lost his arm in Vietnam he only
had a stub so he would put
shop jockey in his pocket he would quit
only in the Jersey this guy verified
from all in New Jersey a shop teacher
was missing the handout he was he lost
the grenade it lost up to here so
whenever you [ __ ] off and he was a
woodshop teacher he was a woodshop
teacher
you think he sliced that on my brother
he would hit you at Google elbow right
to the kidney that you would drop to a
knee right there he didn't [ __ ] around
there was no parents nobody got involved
mr. Taniguchi would come on would you do
you [ __ ] up the drill when I tell you
about pressing the drill whatever what
are you [ __ ] they just give you a
little elbow to the kidney there was a
cut-off that's like that's like that
didn't ignore that wouldn't want only at
the yeah bro that that those elbows when
you lost an elbow that that they're like
it's like mule strength yeah sure in
sweet [ __ ] Taniguchi there's a local
California kickboxer it's local
California but uh pro-am Wayne TIE
fighter
Baxter Humvee was like a multi time
world champion here that he was cut off
I think right it just below the elbow
and they were something fight like
immature fights he had to wear a glove
and then pro fights he didn't have to
worry and it was like an elbow but he
had way different dexterity than like
you would have you're gonna mean because
your arms not in the way I think he
should [ __ ] people up and [ __ ] he's
bad you can't defend it you don't know
how it's coming my humble of missile
well don't they have that that guy Nick
Newell or something is about to be okay
doc trainer Nick no before he's tough
yeah I think they should like you know
glove the nub though I think it's kind
of you know I mean like that thing's
kind of so it's like they should have to
put a glove on something right was it at
all or not it's like a little bit below
I think there's a little bit of the bend
but you you can't armbar that thing it's
not there's not a lot Wow yeah you can
find out the contender series you're a
nice kid and it's an inspiring story you
know no it needs no firing all that [ __ ]
on I was watching some other kid
what a stroke evil oh he's playing high
school football yeah literally have a
[ __ ] walk again you don't say that's
[ __ ] that's crazy there by God he
fell off a bicycle and he had that
[ __ ] tool with his brain or something
and we're walking again now he's playing
[ __ ] high school football all that
[ __ ] gets me all the time
yeah that's we gotta watch the end of
the lose to get that the meaning of
those is [ __ ] they tell you by
trunkman Russia who's getting [ __ ]
who Harvey Weinstein [ __ ] in the ass
young here for the last ten minutes they
show you the black kid with a missing
leg that's saved through Puerto Ricans
in a boat and I'm saying off the coast
of God it's a dress up they say they're
really like sad [ __ ] for them for that
yeah really good inspirational [ __ ] yeah
that's how laddoos gets you yeah you got
anything left after the politics I'm
gonna shoot everybody one like a kid and
they robbed transvestites we'll go into
the bathroom and the whole [ __ ] thing
now at the end look feel good I have an
emotional story from Boulder City Nevada
where they made the fish upend last week
that's the pen that winter moon the
first time 50 years ago Fisher pen so I
saw watch that emotional story hook
there's a Frenchman before anyway we're
talking about training camps yeah and
what's interesting about training camps
is like all right something like jump
just that to children you know Joe it's
tough to be away from any kids now six
weeks and then [ __ ] Santa Fe is
somewhere look what you're gonna be
got the airplane action
un-fuckin'-believable
I'm sitting here two hours not a plane
and fly style I started a podcast and
Pablo Escobar once the puppet show up
for the 20 kilometers [ __ ] and Barry
seal when American made what's his name
[ __ ] crew yeah that's tough going on
the road like I would love to just live
on the road like if I was just married
and we even have this five-year-old are
you [ __ ] kidding me
yeah I leave for two and a half weeks of
the show yeah I've been working [ __ ]
every night except Monday and Sunday I'd
be on the road so Hotel five nights a
weekend three weeks come home for a week
or two go back out but you can't do that
when you have kids unless you're an
animal yeah unless you want your kids
think you want the [ __ ] prison or
something like that yeah sure you're
gone you're gone and I'm telling you it
doesn't work it doesn't work for me
doesn't work for me at all like I leave
six days a month
I could stand that I can barely stand
that that's enough how old your daughter
five five oh it's awesome I'm an old man
with a [ __ ] five-year-old I drop her
off I can't bring more the parents look
at me all [ __ ] weird this [ __ ] you're
like my dad my dad has a five and a
three year old that's he remarried and
yeah it's got little babies that's crazy
yeah that's too low you know it's the
note things and Vic when you're 55
that's exactly 42 kids when you're 55
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] about the heart
attack I think to a specified yeah one
of the day one I'll give you [ __ ] yeah
so nobody's got a fight scheduled here
we're not training do some training in
the game chomping at the bit though any
I should have I have a contract Lee any
day I'm waiting you know what is the
drink big joke same thing I'm gonna keep
switching over them in man kickboxing
I'm just signed a contract I'm just
waiting for a match up hopefully August
September you learned some jujitsu from
[ __ ] Ricky yeah I've been trying make
me a [ __ ] jujitsu man yeah
Mickey Eve Edwards you know all the guys
we've been working a lot so I'm feeling
good good he's turned a corner to like
certain things he would do he like
turned his back he's got enough he's
changed his game and like he just did it
you gets you to him in the high rollers
tournament
few weeks ago did you yeah dude he did
great it's eat submit he's mid to do the
straight ankle lock the did he did
awesome but like you could tell in the
last week like he started like really
like like I'd say the last two weeks he
started really like Baron down like was
getting everything and like was strong
alike using every move incorrectly like
it's awesome it's awesome Joe must be
some home jujitsu Joe let me I'm in some
[ __ ] soon I mean just ask making
I'm pretty much black belt right it's
really give me the black butter I'm
ready yeah yeah I got you dog right you
be surprised after yeah yeah yes I knew
it you started as a Muay Thai guy though
that was your base that's no rest with
no high school around that [ __ ] no I uh
I wrestled for like three weeks and like
sixth grade and then I would they found
the principal fun that coach found out I
was ineligible and then so I didn't
wrestle anymore
and then I started a kickboxing when I
was fifteen I had my first fight at
seventeen sixteen seventeen and then
moved out to LA when I was 19 would you
get paid to my first fight our first
amateur provides nothing nothing my
first pro fight I think I gotta take
$250 first lucrative yeah Lucas I would
go by almost gonna want to go back I
mean not the the money but like it was a
way like way back then you're so hungry
and you could fight anybody there was no
contract so like you can only fight when
these people tell you you could fight
any make it anytime you wanted you every
weekend whoever you could get a fight
man I miss those days she not amateur
fights when I first moved to LA I was an
amateur they had like smoker fights
which is why I moved to LA was cuz
they'd have fights almost every weekend
and all the different wait I gyms
there's a lot of like the wait icing and
and Los Angeles is pretty big there's
probably 10 or 12 like pretty legit Muay
Thai gyms in Los Angeles so like they
would have amateur fights at the gym and
it would calm smoker fights and you know
your gym would like you know all the
guys from your gym would take on other
gyms and then people would sell $10
tickets were ever going to gym and I was
doing I was like
every weekend for I got like nine fights
the first summer I moved out here that's
when you get all the experience you
don't undergo the experience from
fighting like that amateurs because what
you rely on later on in your career is
that you have all those amateur fights
and I have betrayed and overseas over
there and timely at the moment I trained
in timely enough about two months I
wasn't it was cool it's overrated I mean
like you can get a lot of it I think the
overall a lot of people go over to
Thailand a train and they come back and
they're worse than when they left you
know what I mean wiser of the language
barrier and then the you know yeah I
think mostly the language barrier
trainers like not caring you know that
makes sense since you're on vacation
it's like you're here to try it Thai
camp and bukata where everybody goes on
vacation you constantly get people
coming in where they were there for like
two weeks and then they're gone they're
there for a week and they're gone like
how much energy is that that trainer
that paddle we really even put into you
knowing you're gonna be gone like a week
you know make sense
yeah fit it's weird because when you go
to places in LA like especially the
Hollywood area when somebody comes in
and they talked about going to Thailand
it's like when you go to prison and guys
talk about going to different cuz I've
been to that prison really how was it it
was cool man we partly out every night
you like what the [ __ ] is he talking
about partying out every night in prison
there's a couple weeks ago I was in the
movie thank Jimmy there was a girl that
came in and she was like oh holy toy the
you know [ __ ] I train in Thailand hmm
from the three guys who like where had
Bo tank oh my god did you eat the snake
you know the whole [ __ ] deal a couple
[ __ ] impressed the [ __ ] out of here
alright go to the tide Ville down the
[ __ ] corner there on Tuesdays and
Thursday down like kicking [ __ ] trees
behind that building on Western there
years ago I'm not done Kenya yeah years
ago I don't know used to go to a
superbug doe on sunset next to her
compadre and there was a guy that was
always bruised up in there and I asked
him one there why are we moved up but he
knows because I trained at that type
lace behind the restaurant with the
waiters
on Tuesdays and Thursdays and had the
tree with the rope that had the whole
[ __ ] thing back there and they were
kicking the [ __ ] out of each other back
there too
they broke his on him back there one
time I saw him one time with this
[ __ ] sling I know what happened you
were back then he was again they [ __ ]
me up they were they weren't [ __ ]
around they were [ __ ] around white
kids back there white kids were going
back there thinking they could [ __ ]
throw with these waiters and these
waiters were popping them and [ __ ]
yeah that's not sure now you're the old
one of the owners of the yard yeah and
that's just a bull we tie or that's a
full system which is basically I mean we
only offer my tie but we have like MMA
cage and suffer from my training and
stuff yeah it's a more time job so you
do both most do your training down there
yeah yeah and muscle for muscle yeah
yeah I go to MusclePharm a lot a lot of
work down there okay you're strictly the
yard that's good I got that everything
it's awesome it's be a big big beautiful
place like they just decked it out the
you know the the owner Ryan Drexler he's
like a jujitsu guy brown belt competes a
lot from Long Island whatnot it's
beautiful do they have muscle cars in
there like the cars from what was that
Dazed and Confused
not there the just GTO from Daisy
confused throws the ball to the wind
yeah yeah they got the muscle cars and
the muscle arm they got us there's
always like NBA players 2 Chainz down
there like a lot of like it's like you
know it's cool it's a cooler player
milkshakes
not 2 Chainz the rapper I vote to change
but they make milkshakes now they don't
ain't no shame no they have all the
supplements on ship you know they wish
it right here they got an acai place
inside legacy all right yeah that's your
legacy yeah sure man this yes is that
where I went
we're not cool yeah you at the legacy we
enlisted the guy out finish in Austin no
year was hot asphalt damage oh that's
funny damn it biggie
that's funny yeah I remember that no
there's NASA he placed there there's one
around the corner
Green something knockout can place right
around the corner over here yeah I hear
you've been saying really regular
getting dinner jujitsu all the time yeah
and your training what I do yeah the
conditioning class so then I come over
and [ __ ] with me everyone so why by the
time class and it's tremendous I just
don't
I'm 55 I don't have the energy at 6
o'clock it might go to their fight with
young [ __ ] kids yeah
with 11 to 12 o'clock I got a wallet for
sure I got some time we go at night
where shit's [ __ ] up hell yeah I was
thinking about my father we were
supposed to do the podcast yesterday and
then you called we switched and we have
a date so we switched it okay I was on
the train tonight I would have truck
tried it today like last Wednesday I
went to Muay Thai at 6:00 yeah I got
before I mom home I don't have to go on
the road so I've been forcing myself to
outside my comfort zone so all I night I
could go down there for an hour and Coco
some side kicks for Jesus and that night
it's a different assignment yes because
it's in the morning when I go after
class is conditioning ropes and
kettlebells and getting on the [ __ ]
empowerment who boxes and all that [ __ ]
that's tough yeah then the other side of
the class is technically 30 seconds into
[ __ ] ten-second breather you know
right and I would go to jiu-jitsu dog
and I wasn't getting this is what
happened it's it's it's consistency and
it's showing up four times I can't roll
for days cuz that's never gonna happen
four days is a lot for uncle Joey so I
had to figure out how to get four days
even five like last week I was five days
I went to three jujitsu and two more we
ties I did one day conditioning at the
house with kettlebells Nashik say my
workout is us
yeah no no but I told Barry that's way
more than me out of my store
Huggle Monday at 9:00 from Lyon attend
to reconditioning and one of them on
then I intend to reconditioning Tuesday
have the jujitsu conditioning from 11:00
to 12:00 and then I rolled three times
okay
Thursday I will now tell your rolls yeah
I will not go to jujitsu can decide I'll
just go to jujitsu and roll you
following me so this week I'll go
Saturday roll out cuz I got Sunday off
what I give a [ __ ] see already that the
Gion yeah I'm not good that's too fast
that world is too fast that is finally I
get to that I
what's your key game like what chicky
game I'm already like be close guard
close guard listen okay I'm not gonna be
barren bowling the [ __ ] see that
was the problem I was going to places
where they were playing ball us like you
invert I wanna places well we're doing
all this crazy [ __ ] that you feel you
leave there feeling like I didn't really
improve like I didn't I didn't do well
something isn't right and I one day I
just saw a friend of mine with that and
I know he's a black belt I think was
what are you doing thing because you
wanna try a little while I go down there
with you Kenny goes and we rolled a
little bit he goes I gotta tell you
something you're [ __ ] terrible
he goes you're terrible because you're
terrible because I love coaches like
you're not doing what you're supposed to
be doing I tell Mickey he's terrible
every day look what I almost start
swinging on the ball why you doing this
why you all see the problem that we have
is that you're trying to make a living
so you can't tell me I'm terminal
because in today's society
most people who tell their terrible
they'll take their [ __ ] bowling ball
and go give somebody else
double what they're paying yeah that'll
blow smoke up their ass that's a society
we live in as soon as he told me I was
terrible do you think I can went home
and cry
no I listen I go what do I need to do it
goes let's start come here stop doing
the can lock your legs yes grab this
part of the be his wrist here and grab
the top
the back of the shoulder and get your
angle and go just know every time you
just pull them in mmm but eventually you
pull grab the back of the [ __ ] belt
and not he ain't going nowhere trust me
yeah and I can't breathe Joe I'm sitting
there like and you you're going yeah I
can't breathe and next thing you know I
just open one leg and put it on the
armpit and you're on your [ __ ] back
mm-hmm that's that that's the game like
that's a flower sweeper that's it no the
flowers I live the SOTA
cuz with that control with that control
you're gonna just [ __ ] up yours oh I'm
just gonna move my hand to your [ __ ]
collar now you're gonna try the corner
and I got you with a scissor you're just
gonna scissor yourself 3/4 the scissor
you're gonna put your you're gonna go
over me and I'm gonna be right then just
that's all I got awesome that's my game
and then ice is it amount get on top
yeah that's it that's it
can I go for an arm whatever you got
Marianas Americana's and Kimora's that's
it that's it I love it my wrist of [ __ ]
wrist from hitting the bag with no wraps
all those years Mike with gorilla
buddies New Jersey let's hit the [ __ ]
bag you know play no risk no no let's
just hit the [ __ ] bag my wrist is
shot so I can't do north/south jokes and
all that [ __ ] but I [ __ ] love you
Jitsu I love the thought process of it
yeah but so I wasn't getting enough burn
so I went online and I researched what
[ __ ] gives you the most bang for your
body and it's swimming which I love
swimming I can't do because of my ears
mmm how's the water close my balance off
and I get vertigo the water going in
here yeah you just hit your plugs I got
oh you where your plug of it come on
sucks really suck dick yeah I shower
with your plugs on and I still got
[ __ ] oh yeah I got a shower
I got ton I got a millionaire plugs in
my bathroom so everywhere in this time I
didn't plug [ __ ] everywhere you go my
luggage I got bugs everywhere that's
where it happens when I go on the road I
jump in a pool then I go to my room fly
that's gotta be the pressure water
[ __ ] sits
nobody you go to a hotel room you get up
in the middle of night [ __ ] the room
spinning around like you did 22 sleeping
pills you're waking up at Cosby somebody
slip you a Mickey
you know I'm saying that's what happens
that water locks in from the flight so
yeah so I couldn't swim have a bowel
burn the most fat but number two is Muay
Thai training hmm that's the killer
that's an excellent calories in the now
if I go train with you for an hour
forget the [ __ ] ropes and the
kettlebells just punching and kicking
and three-minute rounds five-minute
rounds combinations you kick at me and I
kick at you that's a thousand and what's
that what's great about is your physique
look at his visit he can't I can give
him twenty two steaks nothing happens to
are you a vegan no we barbecue today a
lot of never even gained an ounce but
what you're saying with Mort I like is
there a more fun way to work out you get
that you're developing a skill like a
self-defense skill and you're like you
get the bash it all day like it's it's
awesome you know I think like more time
jiu-jitsu that's like everyone why would
you not do that as a work you're working
out and you're it's like a fun game you
know what I mean
now I go on now I used to go on the road
and be Jitsu NOC boy no idea too many
though we'll say carry you come too
crazy like am I gonna do sit on the road
now I like type of Muay Thai and I go to
a Muay Thai gym and it's tremendous I
sweat my [ __ ] ass off I bring I get
the second bag for free so I bring the
bag with the kneepads the gloves the
hand wraps I bring a protein powder
drink well that mean like you don't need
a partner to like practice point I'm
like you could be at your house [ __ ]
shadow boxing you're thinking about you
know what you're what you're working on
like it's very personal as opposed to
being like Mickey come over I would
think about this arm borrow that you
know what I mean yeah that's that's a
big help but you do so much fun it's
such a mental physical chess game and I
never played Java yeah I never play Chow
I'm gonna play chess move I'm gonna
check this out I never had the patience
that was in prison I still can't play
checkers
when you go to prison I'm gonna do two
things you know how to play prison you
know how to play checkers and you know
how to play handball I don't care you
never play handball before you go to
prison you play handball
yeah checkers is really easy it's just
listen I don't like checkers around I
want to sit in there next to nobody for
two hours [ __ ] mounting I play with
my daughter Theresa no job me [ __ ]
crazy I didn't know what the [ __ ] to do
she had different colored checkers yes
she wanted me to King Harry [ __ ] I got a
king yeah I don't know nothing about
[ __ ] King in people nothing oh my god
well I was Joe talk to me brother
[ __ ] man thanks good when was the last
time you had the was last time you
weren't during my last fight I think was
in December and was in Florence Italy
[ __ ] Philippe Berlin and belts were
kickboxing was good
I went went the distance I want [ __ ]
Italy look at you a flyer all around the
world
yeah Bellator kickboxing was really good
they would that was my all my fights
were in I had three fights in Italy and
then Budapest Hungary it's cool you were
glory for a while too yeah I was in
glory when I was at glory all my fights
were in in the USO I was like the US guy
in one that big tournament yeah no he's
[ __ ] Germans both you guys a savage
is something I'm over here at all but I
very liked you know traveling and
getting out of the country I wouldn't
when I was fighting for glory I was
wanted to be on the cards the European
cards but they always have me in the
states you know people recognize you
everywhere I get recognized a lot and
when I'm weighing about recognizing
Holland loth and even overseas like
quite a bit now what's on Spike Bellator
MMA yeah no Bellator kickboxer I think
it's on it's on periodically okay yeah
cuz I know I get [ __ ] confused I know
I watched kickboxing on that
yeah I saw glory two weeks ago no but a
month ago on the ESPN and that was the
dance at rush yeah I saw the SP anyone
have to do and I saw the weirdest thing
I was sitting there watching with my
daughter and I saw one woman kick the
other one right in the monkey it was the
[ __ ] weirdest thing and the ref had a
[ __ ] stop them what's the ruling on
that that is a warning yeah not a
warning what do you think she did she
went right off
all off and kicked her right the monkey
again and I'm sitting with my daughter I
go watch this is tremendous this is
karate commit yeah he's kicked it right
in the monkey my toes like what the
[ __ ] I don't know I don't know what
the [ __ ] I was I told my wife was like
what are you watching
the chick was holding a [ __ ] right I'm
TV and [ __ ] [ __ ] Matthews all outdoor
[ __ ] and my wife was like what the [ __ ]
you watch I go it stick right now I
should kick their in the monkey my
wizard oh that hurts I go I've been
kicked the monkey - yeah my sister
kicked me one time they don't make cuffs
for women so she go yeah she held off
the first time kicked her the girls need
buck up a little bit the referent how
the other one gave her like a warning
are you ready yes you put it back we
think the girl did hold right off and
kicked her right again the [ __ ] [ __ ]
job
yeah like [ __ ] tremendous sorry about
the way yeah that's all right
[ __ ] God basically I don't want to call
the [ __ ] kick what maybe you want to
open your own gym because I've seen like
there's a lot of fighters I saw Mike
Chandler just opened his own gym Cody
not Cody who's TJ Dillashaw has a gym
now
Gazi yeah sure yeah like there's a lot
of people opening gambling yeah is it
just like it's even more than just
having a place where everything's in one
place you want to have it be your place
and like you like that starts doing
things about your training or I mean I'm
not sure what those guys did it I did it
because I was a I needed to figure out
how I was gonna continue to train and
and uh support my family when I didn't
have fights and I was like wait I mean I
was like 10 years ago well almost 10
years ago Wow open gym yeah the yard in
Lincoln Heights Los Angeles come come
come down good job
you're welcome to go yeah thanks buddy
appreciate as you doc and what made what
did you guys meet um we met up at
Bellator out here there are our former
management uh yeah we met and that you
know I was like I was at home and I was
I was kind of outgrowing my partner's
you know I could I you know just I
needed I needed to train him a bad
[ __ ] and then uh you know we we
connected and I you know I've been
hearing a
I had a couple like connections in LA
and I was like you know chillin shilling
was kind of the final piece or I was
like boom this is why I got to do is who
I should be doing I came out here good
yeah you called me right away but that
was a yeah I saw you down the store yeah
and I thought you were like a castle
rock or some of you guys Eagle Rock I'm
living with Eve Edwards who's a legend
and so I'm picking his brain watching
fights with him like picking his brain
all the time like you know I'm soaking
up the knowledge out here learning a lot
all of you know 26 yeah I'm about to go
on a run about the about to go on a run
that's like yeah for sure gonna starch
his next three opponent says a [ __ ]
bet my house on it for sure yeah this is
not you have to just making me this yeah
I'm serious man yeah such a weird thing
that you have to actually sit down now
now that ever Mays been around for a
while it's not a new sport anymore like
yeah all in a minute keeps it all keeps
evolving and he keeps growing but you've
looked behind we've all seen behind all
the different curtains now and all the
different facades that the different
organizations have thrown at us so you
know exactly it's like when somebody
says to you do you know the longevity of
an NFL running back history is like what
the [ __ ] you talking about and you
start thinking about you and you really
think about it a running back to our
favorites yeah they took care of
themselves they got married they [ __ ]
lifted weights they drank water
you know the percentages but the rest of
them yeah that three [ __ ] years to
Rihanna's so you have to say to yourself
up to 26 I want to get out of this for
the [ __ ] envelope mm and a brain my
building had a brain you know I read
that [ __ ] thing about that 21 year old
football player that killed himself he
had the brain of a 65 year old 21 years
old 20 [ __ ] 1 years old yeah one
concussion one concussion he started
acting [ __ ] weirdly shot himself one
concussion so you have to say to
yourself you know it's like one time I
had a conversation and this and so he
was talking about how he always wanted
to come home like he left his number one
thing wasn't winning as much as it was
not
getting it not absorbing uh you know
interesting that we she wants a couple
family yeah be the same guy you know you
have to go for longevity thing okay I'm
26
what's my run gonna be like well part of
his career did you have that
conversation with I'm gonna sound like
some what it was like that I cried for
he's retired no no this was this had to
be about he was a champion we won't just
eating dinner one night engine roar just
talking with that soir isn't hmm ed was
telling the stories you know you were
saying stories [ __ ] funny guy or he
was swords or both or Eltham Ed's been
on the podcast it's tough yeah yeah to
see both together that one night and
I've had different conversation and but
that might was really interesting
because he was T was telling us the
story about the time when he knocked
somebody out with an elbow he prized
that that Tony Frick hland
yes yeah it's crazy said that he did it
in practice and the coach said if he'd
do that again who God so he would have
to have his wife hold the pillow at life
and to practice that so he was like his
wife hold the living room so when he
wasn't the fight he did it to show his
coach that it worked like little [ __ ]
like that he was telling the stories you
know it's a [ __ ] comedian when you're
a fire you a [ __ ] that guy oh you're a
comedian you wait that's [ __ ]
interesting no it's awesome your wife is
your dream well you got a dog who's that
well what what can I come in for say
he's gonna show you to hold the pillow
right just hold the pillow right here
what the [ __ ] are you talking about last
thing you want to tie me up and now you
want to [ __ ] me hold up no I'm not
doing it yeah but it made sense like
that's the plan like that's the plan
yeah I want to do this for five [ __ ]
years and get the [ __ ] out of here and
then we'll open
one of the [ __ ] girls while you're in
girls
take a little wife up are you ready yeah
yeah that [ __ ] one's new yeah [ __ ]
you [ __ ] young girl a little bit
Ariana be my sugar mama yeah by that
time she's gonna get by me
yeah but it's true you have like a
window ya know I'm and I'm really aware
of that that's why you know where I've
worked really hard and like you know
I've been gearing up for the I think
this next a year I'm gonna really have a
like for a real break out you know yeah
this this dude's telling me I got a
train lesson and he's right and it's
helping but like I you know I've been
I've been making the most of my time
here my time the past year you know
you're taking a supersize nothing it's
less he's telling you the Train water
exactly deal exactly the Train smart and
that's that's right there's a smarter
way to train yeah this Petrelli you
could train six days a week I needed to
hear what train for make the same gains
as if you were training six or more
healthy and even train five because that
fifth day you're doing yoga mm-hmm maybe
you take a [ __ ] yoga class just never
you know something something different
to stretch your muscles a different way
yeah it's so interesting how anime like
a like you know Joe was saying he's
gonna do I'm a no it's it's completely
different it's you gotta work three
different [ __ ] disciplines there's no
set formula it's not like we just if
you're a lineman you practice blocking
all day if you're you know to me and you
practice a if you're on deep if you're
dee dee tackle you practice the swim
move and whatever and tackling like here
it so you have to practice jiu-jitsu at
the proper you know I mean and everyone
then you have to focus in on your own
game it's yeah I think it's I think it's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] I mean it's the coolest
sport I love it
I love my family like I wish I had the
balls to be a fighter like if Ike was 21
now and I grew up watching what I've
been watching as an MMA fan now you have
it in your head how you would do it yeah
how you like you have like seven fights
so you got to start knocking
[ __ ] out and calling people up
like grabbing Joe Rogan by the arm
[ __ ] I'm gonna kill your [ __ ]
mother [ __ ] your father in the ass
I can hold you guys this is more than
right right [ __ ] this is the thing this
is their Bay them not even like trying
to be rude like that like a connor and
so people but just go out there like a
[ __ ] animal stay healthy don't either
you gotta stay in you know because and
then the hardest thing is once you get
it it's keeping it right once you're
good it's easy compared to given that's
like when you were saying out with
Anderson Silva that reminded me like
they say like it's hard for a king to go
to war when he's sleeping in satin
sheets so the people on the come-up who
are grind and like to get up to get to
be the king you know but uh so I think
it's like it's really impressive and
it's strong-minded like for the
champions that stay you're remain you
got 15 [ __ ] they have the same
train of thought that you have the 26
right now somewhere in this country
Oklahoma Arkansas you have to think
about them and think how you're gonna be
different
mm-hmm that's why I loved watching the
UFC in the wall what are you gonna do
going after Joe showing well Joe
shillings a tough guy well he's never
gone up against a guy with my right hand
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] Joe Schilling
has been one up against right and left
hands all his [ __ ] life but some
people just get their right hand like I
wouldn't I see a fighter say that I ride
him off because I think in between every
fight you should come in with a
different weapon I can't really fight if
I was a fine I come with a different
weapon like this time I'm gonna come in
with some jujitsu watchmaking teach me
something out of this [ __ ] world yeah
Joey I'm the teacher combination take
down a heel hook with the points to the
[ __ ] jaw you know some and then the
next time I train I'm gonna go to
[ __ ] jail go Joe give me a complete
[ __ ] history of the elbow
give me the complete history of the
elbow let's go to the [ __ ] Museum
let's break down elbows how they come at
you the whole [ __ ] thing I want a
shot at my elbow and then from there I
don't take and then the next night I
take Joe to take me this and Japanese
master to teach me I sharpen my toes so
I can [ __ ] kick right me out of [ __ ]
yeah and that's what you do but if you
keep telling me about your right hand
guess what Joe I know about your [ __ ]
right there
sorry Charlie I know about your right
here well I didn't know you had that leg
that left little leg kick like a
[ __ ] on the inside Lemlich I
didn't know that what you tell me yeah
he's never gotten the right hand like
mine Unger okay there's your right hand
this tip and it comes in a different
[ __ ] white light like a curve ball no
it dont
unless you got like a fool do elbow you
know I'm saying are you crazy you gotta
come with Sonny where we [ __ ] yeah I'm
sure that's why I always I really did
Lal ways love GSP che always respect
them because one month you'd see them
doing ballet give him one it's like when
Kevin Lee was on Rogen yeah if you
didn't like Kevin Lee and then you saw
him on Rogen when he was talking about
getting kicked in the head and then he
focused on one thing when he learned in
ballet then when you're doing the spins
and the guy grows and goes so you take
ballet goes yeah you gotta prepare for
[ __ ] like that I like that guy there's
Mike Bliss were talking about yeah he
wanted took a ballet class one day he
goes let me see what the [ __ ] maybe I
could throw kick off my toe something
like that who knows remember those shoes
on and throw people off you imagine
running into the ring with ballet shoes
not be believed Emma what happened to
Mick you don't worry about none 13
ballerina shoes there's gotta be a
[ __ ] somewhere that's doing ballet
guys do ballet oh yeah yeah yeah sure
sure
there's two kids on my daughter's class
I shot it with a little printed she made
him win a [ __ ] two to the front and
then the teacher the teacher has a
beautiful little boy and he would get
pissed she would make him come in like
she would watch him he would just sit
there punch the mother's legs for an
hour like I don't want to be with these
dumb [ __ ] all these dumb for you Oh
dirty [ __ ] butts nuts back he is
gonna be a badass I haven't seen him I
haven't seen him in about four or four
or five or six weeks and finally
mother dead let me through another
family out
oh yeah the don't bring this numbering
is something around lay these poor kids
don't know if they're doing yeah yeah
you gotta talk to some real yes guys
how'd she take it when he's old enough
she took a little [ __ ] [ __ ] head
cutting left oh I don't [ __ ] know I
don't [ __ ] knows he got mad at me he
had the one kid with silver shoes on he
can't do that to a kid he's four that's
false advertising
so anybody anybody who sees that sees
that wrong and then she would go out and
talk on the phone what if I was a
pedophile in ballet and I wanted to give
her a little killer stabbing or
something like that with those silver
[ __ ] shoes on you ever think about
that no I don't I don't think elbows and
go to ballet let's look up if I'm going
to ballet I definitely be taking edibles
that's doing ballet Oh to go watch
ballet let me piss and that's a 45
minutes like the [ __ ] do without
every week yeah I do it cuz I love my
little daughter and then work to her
later on yeah but it's 45 minutes I can
reveal you're the daughter
that's under you know I get it yeah
little girls was a couple bags that go
and I sit there sometimes and I go
listen how lucky am I
how lucky am I cuz I'm able to go to
these things those dads are working they
[ __ ] digging a trench they're
training their [ __ ] teaching will we
die I get to go to these things so I get
the opportunity to go I guarantee if you
don't I'm so that's why I do this
yeah that's why I do these little
[ __ ] thing it's not the big things
anybody give you a kid a boat or
whatever it's a little thing that you
know take him on the street you know
many times I've gone swimmin with my kid
over here when she was a baby no joked
when she was a baby I used to because I
saw it on World News Tonight a doctor
and [ __ ] Yale took his kids he had
twins
he was throw him in the pool when they
were three months old two twins I saw it
it was [ __ ] amazing and by the time
they were eight months old they were
swimming under [ __ ] water
they had him up you know those feel-good
stories on wrong news tonight
Jesus I told my wife and I'm throwing
her in the [ __ ] like you cuban you
throw your kid in the [ __ ] water
when you cuban there's no swimming
teacher there's no swimming teacher when
you're in Havana
there's no teachers there's no swimming
teachers they take you by the neck and
they throw you off the pier with the
lobsters and you learn how to swim I
sweat it [ __ ] yeah Cubans don't believe
it swim coaches there's no [ __ ]
Olympic swimming ten so that's a Cuban
rule this is those no I said no good
they teach others from what the [ __ ]
lobsters let me say how prejudiced they
weren't Cuba this is a true story I'm in
town prejudice they were in Cuba in the
50s and 40 if your son was gay they
would take them that rooms call sharkon
man they would take your shotgun don't
think your son's gay we are thinking a
shark number think about that drone
Walter but that's how evil they weren't
cute evil
okay I'm burning your son Wow and the
father the father would do it but mostly
the father would have to do it himself
it'd be like frayed ups yeah you have to
do it himself
take the his own son out there throw
them off the boat Jesus it's heavy stuff
that's how many [ __ ] start right at
least and that's real that's [ __ ]
real was this [ __ ] yeah this uh there's
a show on Netflix called celje about
Celia Cruz on machismo and the first 20
episodes you watch that show man and
your [ __ ] goat Jesus Christ that's
the first show I've ever seen that
they've released those little tidbits
about Cuba because they never released
it huh these [ __ ] people in the
United States I think they're races here
go to Cuba you don't they call the black
neighborhood in Cuba Oh Congo Oh [ __ ]
Congo okay since the 40s they've been
calling of Congo racist [ __ ]
yeah there's nobody more racist than
[ __ ] Cuban people nobody nobody I
don't know how those Chinese people
survived in Cuba that's why they call it
Chino well you think that word came from
cheese you know
well that's Cuban because Cuba had the
biggest Chinatown till nineteen [ __ ]
sixty until Fidel came the biggest
chatter tom was in fronting Cuba outside
of China you believe that [ __ ] huh
that's why New Yor they have
I was gonna say there's Cuban Chinese
Chinese yeah yeah it's good [ __ ] pork
chop with [ __ ] fried rice egg roll
I'm [ __ ] black beans and fried
bananas dollars boom a pork chop with
pork fried rice and egg roll and fried
bananas who's better than you Joe Chile
there's no body and no [ __ ] 'nobody do
you think shark hunting still goes on no
remember when woulda Romero was on Rogen
we talked about our bike wash well he
was here and he goes that he goes this
gay dudes are not my quads now so no no
Bob akua's was the last line of defense
in Cuba they have a longshoreman they
have the ones that looked over it's a
society of men
there's something about cheese no they
don't eat [ __ ] because they believe if
you eat [ __ ] you'll suck anything so
that's how they are that's like the
Mafia in that town that's how they would
like day laliberté sorry Charlie yeah if
you do go [ __ ] the girl talk to you
gotta keep that keep that on rap you and
was that dude English yeah teacher
English English you dude those those
podcasts were awesome I love that [ __ ]
like that good them like the motley the
organized crime like mafia like mob [ __ ]
like that was awesome and it was right
in your neighborhood I know and the
places you're talking about they're so
cool yeah it's awesome
you know TJ English was supposed to do a
book signing last Wednesday in Union
City okay where that book originating
all the stories yeah that's there Mac
are 1100 people will see the sold-out
they pulled the plug the night before
why - alpha 66 showed up with a [ __ ]
was that they like the Cuban
revolutionaries they have this feeling
you need City somebody showed up they
just cancelled it so something must have
gotten out I feel really bad for TJ I
didn't know hmm
I called my buddy who set it up and he
won't pick up the phone so something
went down but I know something's going
on with the mayor anyway
they're trying to get like they don't
like something something went down I
feel bad for TJ because he was really
excited it's a great story it's it's so
interesting that sucks
it's great now where did you grow up
green bro you know like the plane to you
yeah yeah know which is the point field
is bad um I mean they're you know I'd
say the worse is how would you say
playing field playing field playing
fields the biggest northern south
playing stop playing field
there's a plane field that sounded like
five [ __ ] years every college final
there was a kid from playing field yeah
I would say south playing fields like
wrestling games in like in the country
and the basketball somebody every
[ __ ] in the Final Four was from
Plainfield where yeah well I forget
which one of the plane feels it was yeah
any of them and you know that's yeah I
was I played I grew up playing football
daughter I was like the only white kid
who played blue play football I was like
the only white kid who started both like
offense and defense hmm all brothers let
me ask you something Joe would you have
any tops you have a let's fight in the
UFC um I haven't I've uh I don't know
maybe someday yeah but maybe foxy I'm
always pretty much a bit bit kickboxing
so we have something I'll definitely
some of you would be able to do for sure
I mean that's the it's got to be the
ultimate cold for everybody right I
would think that's the big [ __ ] stay
that's the big stage you know you know
it's so funny how the other day I was
watching real sports and it was about
the NFL and it was about the two billion
hundred billion dollar suit that they
settled to pay all the football players
with CTE but the problem is they didn't
pay nobody you know and then pay nobody
and I was telling Lee like it's hard for
me like I watch football now
periodically but it's hard for me to
watch it now because you know these
[ __ ] guys give their hearts to the
[ __ ] you know there's any way to give
your heart to this [ __ ] and now you
don't want to get the money like Mark
Gastineau do yes sure
[ __ ] like he's all [ __ ] up like they
don't give him the money you look at
these big big organization if you know
like the NFL the NBA the NBA I don't
give a [ __ ] I love the NBA this test you
for weed you know they let you [ __ ]
stop as much green as you want suppose
the all these [ __ ] blame UFC like you
want to be in the UFC cuz that's the
ultimate that's it that's as good as a
[ __ ] gets oh yeah yeah that's the NFL
of MMA but let me tell you something
Bellator is making a run for it bro yeah
and I wouldn't say it oh [ __ ] around
I'm not saying they're the best I'm
saying the biggest platform they're the
biggest what the biggest fights in the
world you want to mate like make history
the biggest fights ever really that
that's that's where it's our that's
where it's at I mean no Bellator is
there Bellator yeah they're doing about
tours go for it Bellator is welterweight
Grand Prix looks [ __ ] yeah yeah that
looks [ __ ] Obama gets in that Obama
gets in that I know
yeah awesome what is that start you know
they start to finish the heavyweight one
right we did that versus that what's the
Phenom you know it's only the first
round perhaps I think they so got more
right so it's Chael against right what's
your loss little Bader sitting on a
chair 1 beta 1 Ryan Bader one
ko Woori own one Frank Mir one no no not
you so yeah there's no it's fate or yeah
its fate or against its fire
its fate or against uh check that Li
please
yeah its fate or against whatever the
[ __ ] his name is we were talking about
not Mitrione no guy but charge yeah
Bader
no sailor against uh the first guy we
said [ __ ] yeah
champ yeah yeah and then it's a matron
respect okay so yeah chill be rampage
right so that's gonna be fatal or in
jail and then it's a machinima Ryan
Bader yeah you see they're doing a
rampage versus Wanderlei Silva for I
said Joseph I the winner
no Joe doesn't gain them and fight
another lies when he knocks one of them
no closest savage Joe's got a different
mission Joe's got a different plan I
would take those fights they're big
fights where they fight them the one
labeled a fight they're fightin when
Rory McDonald's fightin Gegard Mousasi
by the way was banned for life in the
UFC for from like you I think he got
young trouble you sada cuz he ran away
from a piss test right you got trouble
in Vegas only know if it was you saw
that this was pretty sure was he was
just like.he like like it was when you
saw it was new and he was like [ __ ] you
you know watching me pee and he's
probably out on maybe something better
like right yeah well so vandalize find
them wonder what label they fight on the
belt oh yeah and where they gonna
finally get Egypt nah I mean fight
where's he gonna fight when I quite an
easy father chill in New York dandelo
yeah yeah
no he's I he's clear to fight with them
yeah I think I think he's good now
um yeah I'm pretty sure he's good when I
when I corner my Buddy Rich petition TOC
for Bellator it was on like Mohegan Sun
like they do go to the Indian what are
they that was I call Indian relation
preservation yeah that is [ __ ] crazy
that you guys fight like in like calmly
and MMA is the same except for getting
punched in the head
some people have three apart some people
have a fear of [ __ ] talking in public
which they if you go to some people know
hey bro go up there and say ten minutes
no no no no no punch me in the face 50
it just blew up there but the
conspiracies I mean when I hear that you
guys fight like it bars for 50 bucks I
got on Wednesday now I'm like that's
what we do you know we have it's like
disco night yeah they throw us three up
guy getting [ __ ] in the middle of
disco night nobody wants to say yes I
really get their dicks up nobody wants
to see three comedians but you know go
put you like a bar and then you graduate
to like James yeah I thought in like a
middle school gym I'm sure you've fallen
someday
do I play Mohegan Sun yeah yeah you know
and the people are watching your people
have lost all their money and they got a
free ticket don't stop yeah yeah okay
good
my first fight was in a bar I wasn't old
enough to get into and the only reason I
was allowed to Animas cuz I signed up to
do the fight like it was a good tough
man contest like to bar you to pay 20
bucks come in so I had 20 bucks signing
the paper or whatever than they didn't
ID me and that was my first experience
and then so after the fight I won the
fight and afterwards it was like
drinking beer and like shake saw me win
and I'll do thought I was a badass I'm
like this is it this is what I'm doing
rest about how much did you in thinking
that nah nothing I want a [ __ ] trophy
and I got you know drunk some [ __ ]
older girls how's it I know things we do
because we love this [ __ ] yeah like
people say then you have people say
where'd you get paid anyway 50 bucks
here an [ __ ] I wouldn't do it those
people today yeah I'm still talking
about fighting or doing comedy but
they're still worried about the [ __ ]
money like they never got me they never
understood that when you do something
that you love it's not really about the
money you don't care about the money you
live on yeah Mickey I live on your floor
yeah I sleep right there how do dishes
not cook and I'll [ __ ] the mow the
lawn and now you won't even see me at
night yeah I won't give in til 2:00 in
the morning and I'll get up at 7:00
leave in the morning a little library
write jokes people understand that
that's when you do when you love
something yeah you don't give us a dream
yeah and even though you can you believe
that you fought the bar one time like
this was your dream to fight it in
Bellator the UFC but wait a second for
tonight you're at a [ __ ] bar really
yeah really
that's that's if they let him fight in a
bar tonight we would go after here we
would go to the bar dude Mickey or I
would want to fight the bar but it's
just not where our lives went but that
still sounds like a hell of a good time
you know mispriced your animation like
for a [ __ ] manga real for a bar tab
or one yeah totally yeah we'd fight for
a bite a currency yeah get a sandwich
you go fight the barista whatever and
just fight like just fight like five
different people
no conditioning
no nothing I mean like I have known that
would shoot steroids just on the
weekends go beat up bounces in southern
New Jersey like they were good down the
shore to beat bounces up all week that's
all they did was look wait we're either
gonna get chicks or we're gonna get in a
fight we're gonna scrap it someone yeah
yeah yeah I get it
nothing like an entire and they have
like bars they have like rings in it
right and they'll have like anybody can
I could have a globe fights inside the
bars and like yeah I would totally do
that
it wasn't like under contractor now it's
like a total dick move but I really
share hurry yeah it's not cool but the
idea of it sounds still sounds good to
me now
that's how I feel like amateurs were
like when we would fight those smokers
all the time when I'm gonna die here was
like you didn't even know you're
fighting until like that afternoon but
yeah you want to go to this thing for
sure
Karianna I was like you get to totally
like the fast that's when you got like
the most experience it was like hands-on
like boom right now for a trophy I paid
probably like thousands of dollars like
a kid I did it with my mirror weighing
in for a fight with my son and like the
sling or whatever like I'm like a little
baby swimming like Newport and uh yeah
take over the fights you guys are
[ __ ] savages well that's just like
you said like we it's the exact
correlation with comedy when hey you get
it it scares you a little but it's like
the most rewarding fun thing to do or I
still gets good 27 years yeah 27 years I
still think about it it could be a bar
with nobody there or it could be in
front of 300 people that paid 25 bucks
the same it and the fear is still the
same yeah for about a minute to a minute
and a half yeah because you're so you're
so fine you're like 27 years I still get
anxiety I still think about quitting and
how before the show think about how the
one booth is not right so I find Lane
who really
crowds and like big shows all over the
world right in big fights and I was like
shocked how how [ __ ] nervous I was
before this high rollers in ground
roller this [ __ ] jujitsu tournament I
did if you know my buddy we just put the
Big E on like a month before the
tournament you know and it's actually
really fun all the grapplers have to
smoke pot before they compete you ask
Eddie called me he was there he asked me
if I wanna go down if I had the kid that
they want it love you to be a part of
for you to be like there are they a lot
though that the game of the MCMC they
would love you to do that too if you
ever you're interested thing it was like
a pea it was like maybe like you know
500 people there or whatever coolest you
Jitsu to him and I've been to because
although the Germans are like stressful
and like we're like you know what I mean
like I did
Brazilians yelling at you and my Pharaoh
stop bah-bah-bah here it's everyone
smoking pot around it's chill and it
that you know that started DJ music
playing like yeah it's really cool big
lawn and mast out put together a really
cool thing
not happy wasn't be real involved with
me real TV was what it was it had what
over 50,000 a thousand views 58,000
views likes for Allah to get bigger and
bigger I'm gonna do one of them I'm
gonna do a combat you just you slap some
[ __ ] what a heavies things I
want to do if I'll do it for I'll do it
for high rollers but yeah exactly the
exact like EBI does the combat jujitsu
yeah so she was
jiu-jitsu with bitchslaps I'm gonna put
someone out I'm what do you say Jolie
around 210 210 to 208 to 11th a roll
with Joe at the next high robot
yeah yes no no no it's the prelim
terrible terrible and I got a start with
him and closed guard [ __ ] thirties
fearing bad does everybody expect me to
be
oh you're just gonna roll over let me
move it oh my god what do you weigh my
god shoot mother oh my god
Joe's great Joe's great Joe yeah my dad
just kicked bottom like Jesus doctor
Christ
but anyway so like we did that turn
about what you were saying like I was
[ __ ] hella nervous I could bleed I was
like it was because I'm smoking weed
like right now or what was it but it was
just it was completely different jujitsu
is not my that game you know and then so
we I didn't even oh my G all of my
jujitsu
has been like noogie and then we put the
key up for the week before honestly we
start with like like three weeks before
the tournament well I hadn't seen this
[ __ ] gonna get ever and I was
wearing he's wearing it three weeks
because I do to Jiu Jitsu tournament my
okay let's you have do you have a key oh
yeah you put onto this thing that's
awesome you guys were saying it's which
I can't even really imagine but I was
like where is it because I've bombed on
stage what is it like when you're losing
a fight is that still fun yeah I saw I
lost my first fight and even though like
just like the rush and uh like getting
yet to like I get like after I do still
feel like I get to [ __ ] assault
someone I get to in front of all the
people want to watch me and see me my
thing I get to try and hurt them as bad
as I get to try and you know within the
ruleset like try and kill them I think
it's it's like it's an awesome thing to
be no other way I'd want to spend my 20s
and 30s you know fights I'd lost we're
like so like you're so wrapped up in
that moment you can't really think about
whether or not like I'm winning I'm
losing and then you wake up and it's
over and I call [ __ ] awesome this
sucks
you know yeah no I like block those men
like out of my like memory completely
the highs are high and the lows are low
don't think about right that's the
hardest part because the let them come
on fun listening to the comedy fighting
comparison that's the only one that I
think is maybe different because if I
have a bet said I have to get up again I
can do either that night or the next
night well they can't but if they could
they would don't like that [ __ ]
in the locker room
right yeah that's just your spot yeah
that's just yo I can't wait a second
some wasn't worried let's do it again
yeah specifically be it caught yet not
yeah when you wake up you're not like
hurt you're not whatever you're confused
just [ __ ] and then you're just mad
instantly that you lost freedom
you know it wasn't like you got beat you
know he got broken down and your hand
got raised like you were ready to kill
him and then he got knocked the [ __ ] out
then he woke up later
and you still rated one of the Kalinina
do you remember you was the fifth grade
somebody came to you and Mickey chug D
is just talking [ __ ] buddy he wants to
meet you three o'clock behind the school
when you're those fights those were fun
Wars and then you got the whole day of
school to think about it oh my god then
you would look at each other the whole
way no that's on now and they get it
what's made you blind
I still have being the sixth grader
fighting this kids like 20 minutes and
again be 20 minutes yeah I gotta have a
bloody nose and a black eye but I kept
fighting this [ __ ] and the next
day we're both in class and the teacher
goes what happened to you [ __ ]
YouTube we were both look like we went
through a [ __ ] war cuz I kept walking
in the head over here for some reason I
kept throwing overhand rights you have
to go through yeah that was one of the
worst feelings I have had is that fifth
grade sixth grade but before that when I
was in New York City out I used to find
really Haitian every other [ __ ] day
for about a year and then when I would
go to for TAC I get into fistfights up
there this fight in the sixth grade
traumatized
yeah try he broke my nose he brought he
busted my lip no I busted his eye I
busted his head I think I cut his lip
but he got the best of me he busted my
nose my nose is a bad [ __ ] shape cola
yeah
and then guess what happened when my
mother died he took me in really yep
gave me but we end up becoming best
there is definitely a bond you you know
I like I feel that with my training
partners especially you know I mean like
there's definitely a bond you get by
beating each other all the time telling
each other in the face the problem was
that he got into he got bail into this
fight for no reason until this day I
can't figure out why we fought and he
felt guilty immediately like afterward
like the next day and it was against him
he was a very nice kid you know he's
still very nice kid let me get some
shoutouts while he's in there real quick
yeah yeah so my man dude bro
you bad [ __ ] patche a free game
Michael Trager rich Himes the second
Gino at speed weed my brother Henry of
Mullah Louis knew werkes knio knio knio
berkos with my men through Facebook
Bethany Brianna and Christopher Walken I
also want to thank my man Scott
Cunningham don't forget to donate to his
GoFundMe page she's coming out here we
need to take care of the whole [ __ ]
deal and then said you gotta get back in
here my brother I wanna get back in here
Joe
[Music]
my brother was a real pleasure you cut
it down I'm happy you finally made it
down anytime you have a fight or any
time you're in the day but I want you to
stop by and say hello
it's a real pleasure like I said I've
always loved to watch your fight and
when I saw you at Burbank Airport that
time he had all blue that story that's
that's that was hysterical that's what
I've pulled up I'm like oh my god that's
[ __ ] John Shelley I was like a little
kid it was like seeing a Pittsburgh
Steeler for the first time oh my god so
I wanted to the airport but I wasn't
just chilling and then I saw you with
your family oh that is [ __ ] jealous
shall I call Rogan
I got your shellings at the airport [ __ ]
music oh say hello man he knows he said
what's up that [ __ ] is saying well that
[ __ ] guy though that guy just looked
up you know saying he just look scary
not the first time may use a comb
restore and uh yeah I think you might
hear mention that story and I was just
so like pumped up the you know who I was
I would have been stoked when I saw you
there I just at the airport you see so
many people so many people come up to
you and Bobby I go you don't leave me
don't look don't bother showing that
yeah probably like Helen had to I am
like when I'm traveling I'm not like
happy Gioconda alright I think arresting
like beautiful your boys are at times
you were having like a good time with
them you have a designer jeans on and
[ __ ] you were doing your thing and you
know man one thing with this in this new
world that we live in
it's great I want you to say hello to me
especially we listen to a podcast but do
me a favor look to see what we're doing
first right yeah
look this yeah time in a place there's a
time and a place for everything you know
saying hello fam is I watched him fight
I saw him on Rogan I went [ __ ] nuts I
didn't even know Joe no you I didn't
know Jordan knew that whole world I'm
like oh my god and so I call them
afterward I still wouldn't go up to a
mother I don't know a person and we
haven't do that it's so weird how so I
gather mummy yeah there's a point in a
level I love Mickey
but that doesn't yeah if I see an
airport at 6:00 in the morning
I think it's a certain like I because I
know like I'll get recognizing all the
time ago sometimes almost everyday and I
would never go but I could think of
there's no one I would think to go up
and go I've never met like hey I know
you as the bah-bah-bah
so that's why I feel like any time I
someone that comes up and says some of
us I'm always is not like the nicest
ever you know what I mean like I'm like
for someone to walk I can't I can't
think anyone I would want to do that to
go up and be like hey dude I have a Baba
you know what I mean right
I'd want to be I got kids you nervous I
chased James Coburn when I moved here
she was awesome and Rogan this isn't a
cure I go rogue and step on it I'll stab
you in the [ __ ] lung we chased him
like for three blocks and I'm doing a
[ __ ] TV show them a visit
Jamie's my Oberon Coburn Coburn Jamie
Knoble was one of Bruce Lee's students
oh yes Stephen Queen and he [ __ ] he was
just
they had great movies he to know all of
these / he was our man went he was he
did a bunch of movies and I always
taught him like Charles Bronson with
gods huh
when I came here I saw my son set the
[ __ ] Acura the the nice one and we
were an amount of light I know Joe Rogan
look to your [ __ ] right look who it
is
it's James [ __ ] cop god damn
and we chased him a little bit he
[ __ ] about then they just took off
that [ __ ] could drive he's doing
like banging me and then like a year
later I booked harmless and every time I
went to shoot my role they kept saying
got canceled the star is sick we're
gonna pay you anyway he got canceled
three [ __ ] times bro finally they
called me they're like we're shooting
Monday and they go he's okay man I go
home I shoot your scenes of always James
Coburn I'm like you're fine Channing and
caught you [ __ ]
I finally got oh you [ __ ] kidding me
I can't see extra buddy though you make
Sur way three times he got me three
times paid man that is I saw him and say
dick to him the whole day we shot our
first scene that night after death it
was shot and he was still a vibrant he
had like a six hour break like he shot
earlier than the game likes
showers we had dinner than it was just
me and him in the room for two hours and
I talked to him a little bit I didn't
break his balls I just you know then the
next day I opened up on it he was
dynamite we talked about Bruce Lee
started crying his [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
you know she have no idea he uh no idea
that dude was yours no idea what he was
like his energy when he walked in the
room because that dude was like
superhuman
he was just breaking it down and I
remember rolling to joy and like Diane
asked him Mike we gotta smoke this and
I'm he had like a Chinese wife or an
asian wife or some and at the end of the
day he asked one of the guys something
buddy got any minor wall around here and
I gave it though the producer I gonna
give this to the producer gave it to him
his [ __ ] and that's my [ __ ] James
Gopal story nice and then I got another
movie he's in the [ __ ] movie like no
her face so like mind's going crazy to
figure out is Jenna hey I'm Peter Coburn
on bed flip way too much I would
actually probably if I saw the rock I'd
probably be like go up to him yeah but
I'd like he'd be like standing there and
say fine yeah yeah probably say
something to you yeah yeah actually I
see the rock with a [ __ ] chick that's
hot I'm not gonna say some dope do I
write the chick I'm not gonna I mean a
rock but I guess out there yeah so on
when I fought sage Northcutt they gave
us a question they're like they're like
if you go fight anybody who would it be
like alive or dead and I said Bruce Lee
and the rock and then they like tag the
rock and stuff and he like tweeted bags
at all I love this tough bastard ba ba
ba then after I beat sage he like sent
me another like another tweet I just be
like you know Congrats tequila's on me
blah blah blah
so I still never got those tequila's
though so I don't know what heroes me
there he is right at the rocks of them
tequila's baby
guys everyone reached out to the rock
what's up with my tequila's
see him with a tuxedo that's gonna dawn
man Flint he got old at the end but he
was a bad [ __ ]
this guy could act this [ __ ] ass off
guys he was in Bruce Lee movies no he
trained with brave and Steve McQueen why
like [ __ ] Bruce Lee guru's out
promoted I know nah I'll move it
[ __ ] look at his IMDB page let's see
what we got it James is [ __ ]
Cobra yeah hey girl skills
that reminds me we also brought you a
Jazzercise we'll show you it's this
little it's a view see have you heard of
the geologists eyes whose size jaws are
size me and Joe [ __ ] with this thing
hold Jamie I'll grab it but it's just
it's just it's like this new little uh
like this is it's this thing that like
actually train like your jaw your neck
and you're like it's so when you're
getting punched I think it's a [ __ ]
game changer we got yeah but just uh
yeah we got you on drilling yeah we're
sure you have you guys are [ __ ]
pretty young time I'm with this [ __ ]
guy I think this was the last movie
really yeah this is it right here just
makes you [ __ ] oh yeah this is like a
[ __ ] win those balls you putting
girls now we'll give this Eric we'll
give Eric it's not gay friend he says he
uses these balls all the time
okay friends nothing yeah you might
check on Alan you might like that though
he might be into that
oh no yeah he didn't you know he did
like [ __ ] [ __ ] that's his big movies
yeah you never thought of that did you
[ __ ] crate Arliss was his last TV a
hundred and seventy four [ __ ] credits
yet yeah but scroll down to the 60s
movies yeah I've seen you haven't seen
those movies have snow dogs Cuba Gooding
jr. come on Oh classic I'm happy you
guys came on in tonight man thank you
very much both these let me know when
you're fighting whatever the [ __ ] you're
doing anything we're gonna see you will
see I'm alright a Friday Friday let me
[ __ ] [ __ ] it what can they follow you're
a joke we can make you Hodgins or
whatever I [ __ ] did it again what'd
you do
oh man you don't know your [ __ ] no I
forgot the [ __ ] same ever I had this
uh no it's uh
Joel it's on Instagram Joe underscore
Schilling and what can they get ahold of
you making that Nikki gall
Mickey like the mouse but no I should
change is Mickey huh mi see case you
wanna be Mickey gee I ll see Mickey
Mouse is Mickey Mouse you just [ __ ] I'm
just [ __ ] Nicky yeah that's it I like
the last name you're like Prince mickey
they ain't no other Mickey's Mickey look
there's people [ __ ] out my name too
it's call you [ __ ] that oh haha Mickey
gosh we thought but this is Asian guys
like oh hello Mickey gar yeah we want
map round we went shooting with map
round 2 you know Matt Brown immortal
there's a [ __ ] Savage
he's surgical he was he's nasty super
happy brah yeah I'm learning a lot man
now I'm working with the best dude I
should beat you know you're going home
for a couple of weeks yeah good I'll be
home for the fourth of July my little
baby sister's birthday and back out back
out probably for like the rest of the
summer
July through August if I can't you know
you know work my brother well it's
always a pleasure to see you guys oh and
for stopping by teacher thanks for
having us right yeah
[ __ ] dynamite I'll aim at the [ __ ]
love you but you're showing he's a
[ __ ] Savage all right I want to thank
our sponsors Fuji sports.com if you need
a game ATS shin guards boxing gloves
imma make whatever the [ __ ] you need
four G's got it for you number two 66%
of men lose their hair by the age of 35
did you know that the thing is when you
start to notice your hair loss it's too
late it's easier to keep the hair you
have them to replace the head you lost
have you seen more your forehead than
ever before as someone mentioned that
you have a bald spot that wasn't there
before have you noticed the power hair
in your brush at home that you've never
noticed before have you fixed your hair
lately and just said where the hell is
my hair gun yeah that's what happens but
thanks to science baldness can be option
okay a one-stop shopping for hair loss
that's what Em's is for hence comm is
one-stop shopping for skin care sexual
wellness and hair loss him connects you
to real doctors and medical grade
solutions to treat hair loss without
having to break the bank excuse me
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your head keep your hair
let's keep your head dawg you want to
look good you want to be handsome
you want a fda-approved prescription
solutions backed by science no waiting
room no awkward doctor visits you save
hours by going
for hems dot-com understand me for hems
dot-com what you do is you answer a few
quick questions you upload some photos
and a doctor will prescribe you the
prescription meds that you need it's
that easy and guess what the product is
shipped to you directly to your door you
don't have to go to nobody's house you
have to go to pharmacy nothing for him
listen to me this is the way they do it
I had a friend growing up Glenn hashaway
he lost his mind every week he'd be
spray painted his head doing this
cutting the hair from here but today
with glue who needs it a girl like go-to
for hems calm right now right now my
list is for one month I'll get you one
month of hymns for five hours five hours
right now while supplies last see the
website for full details this will cost
you hundred dollars if you went to a
doctor hundreds of dollars if you went
to a doctor or a pharmacy me I'm gonna
hook you up right now I'm gonna take Kay
it's over go to for hims calm right now
/ Joe again that's for hems calm / Joey
again that's for hims calm / Joey I want
to thank Joe Schilling I want to thank
Mickey just Mickey [ __ ] just fine and I
want to thank the [ __ ] I thank
you guys for listening for being family
we'll talk to you guys next week have a
great weekend don't forget South Pointe
the 13th and 14th Las Vegas [ __ ] and
then wiseguys the end of the month
Friday and Saturday the 27th over there
in Salt Lake City I want to thank Joe I
want to thank hims calm and I want to
thank Fuji sports.com won't thank all
you [ __ ] have a great weekend
stay black wash your muffler and don't
forget me alright take that [ __ ] meal
leaf Thank You uncle jelly thank you
brother